[Musique]
qui a tout essayé
ce soir
je reçois cette
mr 2
bien sûr canard wallon
ça va je t'aime gars mais tu m'as déjà
appliqué mon ami chance en france je
n'ai pas bien c'est là tu le fais bien
mais merde quoi j'ai plus que ça moi
d'accord
moi je sais pas ce que je vais devenir
l'année prochaine avec la publicité
qu'on va avoir en moi on a rappelé un
robot mon pote tu sors je dis un truc
n'a pas l'esprit canal je regarde le
porno tous les samedis soirs et j'ai pas
l'esprit
[Musique]
j'étais bien là c'est ma place on a
mérité un foutu de réponse tient qui
joue gardien de but dans l'équipe de
foot du mans le mans ben ça c'est facile
yohann pelé
[Applaudissements]
comment s'appelle le porno du mois
dernier sur canal ludivine comment tu
sais c'est
bien plus qu'un banal était mort le
nouveau nom de katsumi que les katsumi
s'appelle katsuni maintenant
comment s'appellent les missions de
saint etienne à midi l'édition spéciale
ouais
mais c'est lui qui est gilles veissière
bas c'est un grand arbitre française
comment tu sais
quel est le spécialiste du foot allemand
à canal attentats temps c'est donc le
mec qui commente les matchs de ribéry
j'ai pas son prénom mais sabatier en
tout cas c'est sabatier jean charles
sabattier
les 500e match de rugby vote retransmis
par canal le 22 mars dernier c'était
stade français contre stade toulousain o
puis
je pense qu'on a à l'intérieur n'a
pas l'esprit quand même
non non non pas du tout c'est
dégueulasse tout ce que j'aurais bien
aimé rester ici non non c'est juste là
pour mon anniversaire
[Applaudissements]
bon je dois prendre mon émission la
mort n'a pas caché la permission de
catherine barma réel m'attend pour la
mienne mais il faut que tu viens c'est
une bonne émission et encore un bon
anniversaire mais je me tiens
jamais
[Musique]
c'est mon papa
alors émission exceptionnelle ce soir
pour fêter mes 20 ans d'antenne en
compagnie de tout ce que j'ai découvert
ou produits surtout mes enfants chéris
mais en france
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est
la vie
je reconnais
et là
[Applaudissements]
alors avec nous ce soir
bien
[Applaudissements]
il s'agit
il va
bruno solo
mais verra
bon nous rejoint par la suite christine
bravo
philippe tesson
laurent boyer
et xavier de moulins
windows
8 en oublier les 106 et ouais c'est moi
monsieur je repars de zéro parce que
j'ai insulté le patronat et les
conditions de travail qui sont
lamentables ce qu'on peut faire une
pause
on a travaillé ensemble on a travaillé
ensemble à travailler c'est un bien
grand mot absolument il foutait pas
grand chose ouais t'as pas changé qu'est
ce que tu deviens j'ai donné des cheveux
à des gens qui n'en avaient pas
laissé tomber l'humour grenier encadre
la source tu m'as beaucoup monté tu sais
oui enfin je déconne en fait tu m'as pas
manquer du tout parce que tu me prenais
une tonne et depuis que tu es plus là je
me fais des couilles en or
à temps mais tu sais pas qui c'est c'est
philippe au corps
[Applaudissements]
je t'aime
mustapha est là mais si tu reviens
j'annule tout
je n'ai jamais reçu ce message
optimiste
évident moi je connais c'est ta gueule
mais j'étais incapable de mettre un
prénom dessus c'est pas toi qui sera les
inondations et le pari bien se passer un
nom aux côtés de grincheuse
va très bien pour toi toc toc au palais
royal laurent baffie est un sale gosse
en tournée en europe 1 ça marche très
très bien tous les dimanches de 11h à
12h et l'émission n'a pas de titre la
semaine dernière ça s'appelait j'ai
envie de faire caca ça dépend
de la qualité l'inspiration ça ces
applis si vous êtes bien sur rtl c'est
ça oui
mais ça c'est pour emmerder julie
s'appelait aussi une fois que j'avais
j'ai couché avec elkabbach parce qu'elle
a du mal à dire ces mots là la semaine
prochaine ça va s'appeler ma vieille
chatte perd ses poils
alors maïtena avec trois élections
les nouveaux explorateurs le dimanche à
15 heures sur canal + le scellement tête
de mioches le samedi à 19h20 c'est ça
c'est ça nous quel est ce juste un
millier ça marche mieux des phases de
jeu
bah ouais je les nouvelles émissions que
ça va être planète 2048 le dimanche à 12
heures sur place et qui parle de de
développement durable conneries
c'est sa mère n'ont pas bien yvan le
bolloc'h bonsoir
montceau bonsoir
on est les deux plus belles réussites
des deux d'un coup alors nous parlerait
genre de votre encyclopédie glace
mais j'attends nuit thierry ardisson je
voulais juste prendre une dotée de très
bonnes vannes ou en tout cas une de tes
bonnes vannes écrite par un très bon
moteur le bloc a enfin trouvé un boulot
qui va avec ses chemises et les gitans
dont vous êtes en tournée dans toute la
france avec votre groupe ma guitare
s'appelle reviens dans une tournée qui
s'appelle tous les chemins mènent aux
roms mais tous les chemins le tome c'est
un c [ __ ] série des jantes en alu
sur ta caravane ou pas juste non mais
répond par l est pas bonne les par bones
ne répondent que quand elles sont bonnes
je chante on a lu sur la guerre puis de
garde moi c'est pas bon un cador dehors
et son anniversaire et en hommage
est ici pour hors jeu c'est plus un
chinois pour toi comme il est là depuis
quatre mois je suis là pour toi ce soir
c'est pour moi la fia pour défendre le
passé je suis l'avenir tu es le passé et
j'avais envie tendre
de vallorbe c'est comme un dvd avant de
la laci le dvd
rendez vous en terre inconnue mais oui
intonations celle de pez n'en a rien à
[ __ ] du dvd de l'aube ce n'est pas
rien à [ __ ] j'ai piscine des plus
belles expériences de ma vie c'est vrai
que ça a été tourné en studio
non je suis venu pour toi tu es riche
c'est vrai ça ça me touche en effet
merci
[Applaudissements]
mais dès ce soir bonsoir
vous êtes ici pour l'amour dure trois
ans mais la garde à vue 36 heures
qu'elles soient en fait une arme entre
un policier et un mec et de la danse est
magnifique comme bouka c'est un pamphlet
est un pamphlet parce qu'aujourd'hui on
peut même plus drogués dans la rue
c'est scandaleux il de face caméra des
linteaux n'ai rien senti de révolte je
vous propose d'envoyer ce soir un
message aux jeunes du genre pour passe
groguhé donc si vous vous droguer
engagez-vous dans la narine si vous
j'en suis drogué nous finir est
animateur au cercle sur canal
+ à la ligne
je lis mon travail
j'ai eu peur du regard amusé des
buts à rien et c'est le siècle a dit ne
me secouez pas je suis plein de larmes
c'est
donc le cercle sur canal+ cinéma plus
l'écriture de votre prochain livre au
secours pardon j'ai relu le précédent
il a travaillé aussi pour jean piot fait
des interviews chaque mois pour jeep you
françois bayroux alain finkielkraut
playboy dans la version de yann assez
critique littéraire à voile boy c'est
une de mes grandes fiertés pas oublier
que je suis chroniqueur à lire oui on va
vous montrer des singes et vous soutient
à qui sont six arlette chabot non non
c'est qu'ils carrier non tout le monde
je m'attends n'en sera pas bien avoir
justement c'est comme ça mais j'aime
tellement
ça
[Applaudissements]
ce sont les seins de la première dame de
france alors que dans lequel ils vont
soit vous à nous ce soir ou jamais tous
les soirs donc sur france 3 vous avez
reçu le prix philippe caloni de
l'interview
[Musique]
une calèche carbone interviewer qui
était
surprise
mais c'est normal parce que c'est une
calomnie nattawut vais pas les people
comme vous il est arrivé des hommes
politiques des futurs présent de la
république des grands musiciens c'était
donc vous le connaissez pas il n'était
pas sur la liste de vos attaché de
presse respectives mais ça a été un très
bon
si je croise et pourrait
récompenser
chaque année un intervieweur il faut que
le premier ça a été moins mais il y en
aura d'autres je les avais la chance
pour gc remarque année le dire c'est
qu'elle est du calme du parti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
frédéric taddéï devant nous tout est
pour vous rendra à france 3 à pétain
j'ai craqué partirai jamais
françois ça continue ces syndicats sont
feuilleton au revoir si vous connaissez
bien france 3 on va faire une interview
son absence de droits
[Musique]
alors à quelle heure commence le 19 20
19h20 mais non
18h50
heureusement la croyance c'est pour ça
que je rate tous les jaunards qui
présente des chiffres et des lettres
patrice laffont
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comment s'appelait l'émission culinaire
de joël robuchon ça c'est facile c'est
avec c'était avec comment il s'appelait
là l'expérience et repoussant mitterrand
bon appétit bien sûr
je pense qu'ils vont me définit le mieux
mais qui savent pas ça que présente
frédéric courant et jamy gourmaud
sur france 3 oui on souffle au parlement
dit clairement que la culture sont
condescendant et méprisant voilà pas dit
on est là bas mais se redresse un peu
lent mais pas sorcier ben c'est pas
sorcier
dans le segment
qu'est ce qui est diffusé à 13h05 tous
les jours le porno pas non
13h05 tous les joueurs sont tous les
jours c'est pas une émission qui
s'appelait 14-15 non
30 millions de manille oui
l'inspecteur qui peut dans la chambre il
s'appelle horst wind offshore
[Applaudissements]
allemand aussi aurait pu devenir celui
qui jouait dans
l' il va y arriver citez moi un
présentateur de la météo sur france 3 de
carolis non
là je sèche contre à
gentilly intérêt de savoir les femmes
jeunes ouija mienne
j'ai pas de famille c'est le deuxième a
mené
[Applaudissements]
il ya ainsi florence klein et jean marx
ou amis avant de nous priver de france 3
a commencé sa carrière dans rasta
baignoire sur france 2
alors disons à 19h en semaine c'est
qu'elle est très jolie c'est une bonne
émission c'est bien 19 20 et s'est donc
repris de volée nicolas sarkozy est
l'une des seules mais dans morgan
non là on joue pas on joue à si basse et
autres que le beurre bravo
rappeler comment s'appelle le bar
central de plus belle la vie c'est
christine bravo c'est ça se passe à
marseille c'est la plaie le supporter
non comme ça a pas mal ah bah non c'est
pas ça la bande rejoue à rome la
compagnie austral
ses peintures et j'ai regardé temps en
temps on y lit bien que l'humour et le
dis pas que je regarde ses gardes je
vais te dire tu vas finir intervilles
toi
3 c'est mort
salut
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue
alors l'invitée ma naïveté et la marine
américaine
vous présentez peut-être de mioches sur
canal+ family oui oui et donc je vous
faire une interview peut-être de mieux
[Musique]
alors je vous dis le début d'une phrase
il doit faire attention aux les mains
aux peaux de lapin blanc
maillot de bain
qui jouent non tu me fais attention tu
fermes ta boîte à camembert
perte de sens pour le décès
attention ce qu'on sent une souris verte
qui courait dans l'herbe la trappe à
part à la cérémonie
attention comment sa musique au 50e wes
il affiche de belles ton était à comment
s'appellent
les revenus ou quoi
comment s'appelle le chien de mickey
[ __ ]
c'est concentre maintenant
y'a pas d'arêtes dans voici
maïtena c'est celui qui dit qui est
le mardi 10 août à 1,6 tonne soit
ouais ce qu'on mange à midi
articule quand une calèche nom à
particule quand steve est un super club
james
bond
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
continue avec les infos de blako
mais qu'est ce qui lui prend à sarkozy
d'envoyer des renforts en afghanistan
sans faire voter nos députés s'il avait
consulté les élus de terrain il l'aurait
mis en garde sur les conséquences de
cette décision parce que l'afghanistan
c'est le premier producteur mondial
d'opium et le troisième pour le cannabis
alors en envoyant nos soldats là-bas on
risque de faire s'envoler le prix du
shit et de l'héroïne voire de créer la
pénurie alors bien sûr la drogue c'est
pas bien mais dans nos banlieues ça
alimente une économie souterraine et
s'il ya pénurie ça va faire baisser le
pouvoir d'achat du coup les gens seront
en colère et ils n'auront même plus de
quoi fut même qui joint pour se calmer
faudra pas s'étonner si les émeutes
redémarre à la rentrée
après l'incident de la banderole
déployée au stade de france par des
supporters du psg la police examine
toutes les vidéos qui permettrait
d'identifier les individus les plus
agressifs afin de les interdire de stade
l'enquète s'oriente notamment sur l'un
d'entre eux qui s'étaient glissés dans
la tribune présidentielle
l'enquêté a déjà permis de retrouver une
vidéo où il avoue être un supporter
acharné du psg qu'il chérit princes pour
le psg non non c'est non sensique moi
j'y vais pratiquement tous les quinze
jours où vous taclez les trois semaines
c'est un c'est un grand bonheur une
autre bande vidéo encore plus
accablantes montre que ce hooligans est
incapable de maîtriser son agressivité
quoique richard deschamps peut le dire
des champions
berbatov qui grâce à ces documents la
police ne devrait pas tarder à retrouver
et son identité exacte et son adresse
afin de lui signifier son interdiction
de stade définitif
ça alors une pleine page des loges pour
l'arche de zoé dans le parisien mais ils
veulent se fâchait clore les taux ou
quoi qu'est-ce qui leur prendre défendre
des trafiquants d'enfants et pendant
qu'on y est pourquoi pas lancer un appel
aux dons pour réunir les six millions
d'euros de dommages et intérêts qui
doivent aux familles amène en attendait
c'est parce que l'article on remonte à
2006 on comprend mieux en aidant les
orphelins du tsunami eric breteau avait
fait la une du parisien mais seulement
dans l'édition du val d'oise c'est sympa
d'être un héros dans le val d'oise mais
on peut rêver mieux du coup il s'est
peut-être dit qu'en ramenant des
orphelins du darfour qu'ils feraient
cette fois la une de la presse nationale
eh bien chapeau eric 1 quelle réussite
après avoir été arrêté incarcéré et
condamné aux travaux forcés au tchad il
a fallu pour obtenir son rapatriement
que la france sauf le président tchadien
d'un coup d'état et voilà qu'à peine
gracier le soudan lens contre lui un
mandat d'arrêt international
waouh quelle histoire si je puis berlioz
rachète les droits pour plus de 6
millions d'euros il sera même
bénéficiaire
sarkozysme dénoncé ces jeunes jeunes
dénoncé ces jeunes qui restent
meurtrier sur la regarde il faut les
arrêter avant quand les jeunes faisait
du bruit au pied d'immeubles fallait
leur tirer dessus à la carabine pour les
faire dégager bientôt ce ne sera plus
nécessaire grâce à beethoven
fait le nom d'un petit boîtier qui émet
des sons stridents uniquement
perceptible par les moins de 25 ans la
technique est déjà utilisé dans des
centres commerciaux en grande bretagne
ou dans des écoles aux pays bas pour ne
pas que des élèves traînent dans la cour
de récré pendant les heures de classe en
france une cinquantaine de syndics
d'immeubles ont acheté cet appareil
vendu 850 euros pièce alors bien sûr on
entend déjà les belles âmes dire que
c'est un scandale de traiter les jeunes
comme des parasites mais soyons
réalistes un jeune ça bouffe comme 4 ça
ne produit rien et ça ne pense qu à
forniquer à la limite on se demande même
à quoi ça sert les parasites faudra les
tuer dans l'oeuf pour s'en débarrasser
ça tombe bien il paraît que le boîtier
dangereux pour les femmes enceintes
[Musique]
la moitié ont dit jeunes après après le
spray anti sdr il dit dans une société
où on commence à avoir des remèdes pour
chaque nuisances possibles et
imaginables gueule nations angolaise
broussard et fachos l'usure dans les
cours d'école en langue dans ce pays de
droit de liberté de dallas
bravo bon bien un endroit où on a besoin
de vivre en société c'est l'école et si
on supprime dans les mêmes dans les
écoles l'idée que des enfants se
rassemblent enfin bon enfant non
mesdames quoi faire avec la banderole
aussi qui a été déployée au psg ouais il
n'y a pas de fautes d'orthographe c'est
déjà si la connerie été remboursés par
la sécurité sociale et aux hooligans
serait mieux
encore l'afghanistan donc sarkozy engage
un avis mais trop tard et trop tard
le rebond d'hier va te faire [ __ ] non
non je l'entendais puis abandonnée je
rebondis
des avis maintenant bien sûr maintenant
je suis un petit peu je suis un artiste
on part j'ai envie qu'on implique dans
le truc j'ai envie qu'on me demande
bonsoir intéressés par mon avis non le
fait reculer en chambre non non alors on
me suis désolé mais ma vie formidable
j'avais plein de trucs qui
n'ont rien à [ __ ] que j'allais avoir
fait moins tout ce gaz est mal tombée -
et maintenant c'est le zapping laurent à
la trouvez moi un coup de gueule c'est
moi un coup de gueule à ce que 5 ans
c'est incroyable histoire
s'ils font tellement donné tu vois c'est
faux faux nom pense quoi laurent baffie
par exemple ça va avec le reste
de la tournée suivant de merde j'ai même
pas dedans banc laurent labit ce temps
j'ai acheté une maison à kaboul eh ben
concrètement un cabinet
boulot cabourg et ben je n'y vais jamais
cette expulsion d'achat comme ça mais le
week end jamais l'ombre à kaboul allez
on y va pas payer vous avant d'acheter
une maison parce que parfois c'est loin
on ne doit pas cacher
[Applaudissements]
à lorlanges de jouer alors voilà voilà
un truc qui m'énerve tu as ces connards
ils vont là bas ils prennent des enfants
de tchadiens pour la ramener en france
beaucoup tafer qui regarde
ce sont d'ailleurs que les contribuables
français vont payer une 6 millions
d'euros pour cette conne emilie lelouch
qui une fanatique en plus cheap à elle a
quelque chose dans le regard de deux
fanatiques vous trouvez pas je vais
visiter son père commence au niveau
des yeux des gens qui partent dans
l'humanitaire peut-être qu'ils ont
dérapé dans quelque chose de fantastique
absurde mais là qu'ils ont mis les
haillan solutions
d'info ses huit ans de prison et qui
payent eux lancé minute rend pas compte
de ce que c'est que la prison alors
imaginons fred avec imagine que des
tchadiens soient venus en france et
qu'ils aient pris sont trois petits
français pour les amener au tchad ça
fera un scandale et là on s'en branle
son côté est ce que c'est des tchadiens
tout le monde s'en fout il était censé
rester huit ans enfin avec les remises
de peine peut-être trois quatre ans en
prison mais il ya juste un troc qui a
été fait par rapport au président en
place mais sera-ce
français déjà tu as vu samedi dernier
les handicapés tout le monde se branle
des handicapés tu vois non bien 600
euros par mois et là on va donner 6
millions d'euros sur 36 millions de
francs clients a dit qu'il donnerait pas
stéphane le gouvernement français va
donner je peux te dire et c'est un
scandale et j'aimerais bien que j'aie
des tchadiens qui viennent en france
chercher des petits français on verra
comment ça se passerait tout ça est
inscrite à quelque chose à dire toi les
saisir de tes enfants il est là bas dit
il
chef de village en deux mois
sans que son père
jay van den qu ils sont morts de rire
alors autre chose en actu la flamme
olympique sympa on y va tous là à il est
un peu emmerdé avec cette histoire quand
même notre merde qui l'emmerdé parce que
fondamentalement je pense qu'il est
plutôt de la ville de robert ménard mais
bon sauf que il peut pas véritablement
s'investit en contre le mouvement
olympique puisque paris est déjà une
ville qui les a raclé mais déjà
plusieurs reprises la france est un des
pays fondateurs de l'esprit de
l'olympisme et aux dons qu'il est très
très en mer des eaux vous entendez mais
on va y aller sur sur le parcours de la
flamme il faudrait quand même qu'il se
passe quelque chose là bas que ça reste
pas juste un coup d'épée dans l'eau qui
ce passe quelque chose à à pékin savoir
que c'est pas qu'on refuse de serrer la
main des officiels de la fin un truc tu
sais quoi là la première fois que j'ai
été embarqué par la police s'était pas
l'autre jour avec mon histoire c'était
au salon du livre il ya trois ans le
salon du livre à paris et a été
consacrée aux écrivains chinois il
n'avait pas invité le prix nobel de
littérature gaoxing qui était un
dissident et j'avais mis un tee shirt en
son honneur et la police m'avait mis
dans un panier à salade déjà donc voilà
le pays des droits de l'homme devraient
avoir honte du saint suaire est mon
patient le 13e sur tout
et nous l le peuple chinois il ya peu il
ya que des officiels qui s'expriment les
journalistes on pas en droit de
s'exprimer au tibet au massacre mais de
manière mais c'est pas une légende
malgré ce qui nous dit c'est pas vrai il
ya passé la répression s'est pas de
massa qui a dû massacrant tibet et on va
aller là-bas mine de rien défendent la
flamme olympique en faisant fi de la
charte olympique qui dit quand même des
choses bien précises la charte olympique
qui parle au nom de la dignité des
épaules que jeux olympiques du bytecode
toi et regarde la vie très pointu là
dessus mais ça nous embarquerait trop
loin après un enchaînement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bb&t va nous quitter pour aller en
prévente et 20
ans mais je vais être remplacé par
higuain qui a le même niveau d'alcootest
que moi oui qui s'appelle jean luc vers
le sud moins bon
[Applaudissements]
c'est moi
là on gagne en style gt qui chante
l'amour ton salaire
voudra consignés depuis voilà on s'est
réconciliés bien entendu qu'on s'est
réconcilié ça nous a coûté une fortune
en champagne est un groupe de rock je
suis l'aîné millibars six mois
les yeux
[Musique]
je suis bravo bonsoir ça non comment ça
se passe on n'a pas tout dit chez
laurent ruquier ça se passe ça s'arrête
bah voila moi je trouve ça très bien
ouais ça s'arrête la france aussi non je
trouve ça très bien parce que ça nous
permet de faire autre chose on s'endort
missiles feydeau fort maintenant mais
cuisine moi je vais la produire
on
va vous allez faire quoi la prochaine à
peut-être été mais moi je vais faire du
commerce équitable donc votre truc de
commerce équitable c'est bravo les
routes c'est ça c'est bravo et good
point fr alors et je tiens absolument à
dire aux gens pas du doigt a créé ce
titre il coûtait ta carrière
faut savoir qu'un body en chine ça coûte
10 centimes d'euros ça m'a été proposée
à 10 centimes d'euro
et en france et je ne vais pas lâcher
monsieur sarkozy ni le ministère
de ça oui et non
mais je sais pas qui s'occupe des
experts des commerces et des commerces
qui ont d'ailleurs non non c'est le
ministre d'alzheimer sam revers
d'anciens combattants
même battre pour que la bouffe
hockeyeurs issus de surf et sur les
vêtements figurent l'origine des
produits ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui mesdames et messieurs quand
sarkozy va avoir sur le point qui veut
dire c'est ce qui va faire oui à tout
parce que bravo il c'est plus simple de
dire oui que de discuter christine ouais
t'as envie de vous faire une interview
mais allez un peu vous me promettez vous
n'avez pas partir en courant ça va
dépendre non non on va faire un deal si
elle vous énerve ou me fait un signe
genre comme ça et je me rêve alors je
vais vous dire une chose je suis très
heureux d'être ici je suis très émue
fière quand je suis ému je suis pas très
drôle en général j'ai vu souvent émus -
ici ému te revoir et ému de voir le
bolloc'h est muté dans le petit les
collègues lui parce que je les ai eues
sur les plateaux son plus beau souvenir
de cette année - et loire
je savais depuis en réalité son avis pas
mort tu fais ça et je m'adapte dont
l'interview christine bravo
[Applaudissements]
brigitte bardot ou chaîne bravo méthon
rentré 5 2 dans
ses fins ah non c'est délicat ouais je
pleure ce soir
jeff nous avons alors la fiat bravo
mignon sur le tombé non non non non
photo mh chez ruquier à l'entente une
autre je suis gens tentent une autre ou
non je n'ai rien dit je me lève et je te
bouscule qui travaille pas
je vais attend
déjà attention attention partie 2 3 ça
consomme énormément savent que s'ils
bravo bravo à alençon à tirer non c'est
trouver la solution à l'ensemble
alors la vie à sept
j'te jure il a faim n'est pas il est
marquée elle suce beaucoup
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en commun j'attends c'est connu on s'est
connu ses revenus on s'est perdus
c'est comme si je suis d'accord si
j'avais des faiblesses à laisser un bébé
briller oui j'étais mariée moi je trompé
mon mari oui quoi
ça c'est pas moi c'est pour ma part
jamais mais hot que c'est
nous sommes
sinon c'est pas méchant elle se braque
me simard
les deux
foncez
bon c'est pas drôle
attention musique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
schenkel maintenant stéphane guillon
[Applaudissements]
ses fans diront fed avant le zapping de
canal c'était le zapping de canal avoue
stéphane guillon pour la semaine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors si stéphane comment ça va pas la
semaine c'est quoi c'est votre portrait
laisse tomber
[Applaudissements]
sam anniversaire c'est la surprise
cette semaine en france un événement
occulte tous les autres pire que disco
vous n'y échapperez pas les vingt ans
d'antenne de thierry ardisson
véritable culte de la personnalité
émission article vsd consacre trois
pages au grand timonier de la révolution
télévisuelle des photos passionnante les
clés de thierry
son portable ses lunettes et là
attention trois photos différentes ses
lunettes de soleil de vue et enfin son
étui il manque malheureusement une photo
du petit mouchoir pour les essuyer
peut-être pour ses 50 ans de télé et là
il y aura aussi sur nos des cas
plus lent encore vsd a photographié la
penderie du maître une palette de
couleurs impressionnante du noir foncer
au noir clair
c'est ma femme avait la même on
gagnerait 3 heures tous les soirs avant
de sortir
l'article dévoile un thierry méconnu
l'homme aime les bracelets de force les
peignoirs nid d'abeille et s'asperger
dhabi rouge on se dit tiens
on s'est dit tiens une biographie
d'orlando non non c'est c'est bien un
team naissance du petit thierry pierre
clément ardisson en janvier 49 à
bourganeuf beau bébé on ne connaît pas
son poids en revanche sur cette photo on
note qu'il a déjà un cul bien possible
[Applaudissements]
enfin ce morose près d'albertville vous
vous emmerdez paris-match dites-vous
était la seule distraction et bien nous
aussi cette semaine paris match nous a
distraits thierry ardisson prend un bain
si un enfant solitaire d'albertville
nous regardent souhaitons que ce cliché
le fasse rêver vous n'avez pas beaucoup
de copains car vous déménagez sans cesse
au gré des chantiers votre père est
ingénieur le tunnel du mont blanc c'est
lui 39 morts en 99
les sorties de secours ce n'était pas
son truc autre fait d'armes le chauffeur
routier qui a tué coluche s'appelait
ardisson serait sans doute un cousin et
vous thierry enfants vous incendié une
grange
malheureusement personne ne danse fine
pointe rôle le tunnel du mont-blanc
coluche une grange et moi ardisson m le
démon
puberté difficile vous êtes complexée
gros cube bouton pas assez baraqué
aujourd'hui il ya un truc qui s'est
arrangé plus de boutons
du maquillage à 12 ans tirait écrit son
premier livre l'histoire d'un homme qui
fait l'amour à sa chienne oui quarante
ans plus tard pas de grands changements
thierry vie avec une jument
[Applaudissements]
signalons également une amourette avec
une chèvre lors d'un déménagement à oran
depuis en souvenir vous ne dites plus
jamais oui mais ouais ouais ouais
bachelier en 66 nombreux voyages
installation en grèce est ce qu'on peut
voir la photo de la période greg de
thierry
rey village people
arrivions stop à paris en 69 tentative
de suicide en 70 vous vous raté je
précise pour nos amis belges et plus en
plus nombreux à regarder les divers
petits boulots vous entrez dans la pub
parce qu écrire des livres ça ne paie
pas quoique aujourd'hui l'histoire d'un
type qui stoppe sa chienne il ya
beaucoup d'éditeurs qui seraient
intéressés
88 première émission télé et c'est pour
ça que nous sommes là ce soir et pour
l'occasion je laisse la parole à un de
vos amis
bonsoir
à arêches dans un climat familial
étouffant le petit thierry rêve de
strass et de reconnaissance en 62
l'achat d'un téléviseur brice pour
toujours la solitude de l'enfant
d'albertville bercé par le charme d'une
denise glaser la culture d'un françois
chalais et l'impertinence d'un jorian
thierry devient enfin ardisson il monte
dans sa chambre s'habille en noir et
refuse de porter des slips et lorsque
dans le poste zitrone demande à
l'infante d'espagne s'y attendre un bébé
la bouleverse thierry murmure entre ses
dents est ce que sucer c'est tromper
naissance d'un poète cathodique génial
dont la prose trente ans plus tard nous
bouleverse jamas êtes-vous clitoridienne
vaginal ou anal
thiery porte désormais des lunettes
noires enchaîne les nuits blanches tout
le monde en parle rive droite comme rive
gauche n'en déplaise à carolis magnéto
serge bonsoir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci
ouais merci on peut retrouver stéphane
guillon lundi prochain à 20h30 au zénith
de paris dont la cinquième édition de
rire contre le racisme
les bénéfices seront reversés aux
associations participantes comme sos
racisme on peut le retrouver en tournée
dans toute la france sur le site
canalplus.fr est ici la semaine
prochaine et nous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bromont choix tous les bienvenus
[Applaudissements]
alors laurent tu te souviens comment
j'étais engagé l'an donc laurent marin m
me dit je fais une émission sur chez
google radio de merde maintenant radio
fun radio et il dit je vous invite jean
ont j'ai pas trop le temps on dit j'ai
pas trop le temps que les villes
intéressées voilà ça m'a fait rigoler
attention tous les jeunes humoristes ne
doivent pas me traiter de connard ça va
marcher qu'une fois qui se souvient de
la première grande vannes de laurent
baffie dans double jeu je vois je dirais
que c'est s'est passé avec dorothée non
c'est que jugnot avec j alors je demande
quelle est la plus grosse peur tu es tu
répondes les chanter chez aparté cheveux
longs
et croyez lui la déchéance aujourd'hui
la ja non il ya eu aussi de nadine de
rothschild qui donnait des cours pour
recevoir les gens est ce que ceci s'est
trompé
laurent ton meilleur souvenir de tout le
monde en parle par le cheik
écoute le chèque qui veut parler du
dernier puisque les premiers n'était pas
un formidable atout bien après je crois
que c'est toi mon meilleur souvenir de
ses jantes
et des meilleurs souvenirs c'est de dire
des horreurs ont et qui pouvait passer
nulle part et toi tu lé passé et ça
c'était extrêmement jouissif - lolo
[Applaudissements]
et mon pire souvenir
heureusement ne pas tirer les femelles
justement monsieur
[Applaudissements]
sur les rumeurs zoophile
[Musique]
alors dans le privé les gorilles sont
super complexé car leur dis donc c'est
pas une rumeur 6 cm alors dans le privé
les léopards porte des strings couleurs
put rumeurs parues
dans vivo a sondé glauber récupération
des brodeurs lra sont des gros baisa il
peut voir 20 millions de descendants en
trois ans oui c'est vrai oui c'est vrai
c'est donc élever les éléphants des
thèses comprennent leur défense préfère
se débrouiller très très bonne vanne
donc privé les genres son pdg michel oui
oui
oui là on a peut-être capitale on a
peut-être capitale déjà à l'époque ça se
voyait
sociale à fo la shoah
à dans le privé les dauphins organise
des gangs bangs l'histoire de ce marais
oui ce sont des [ __ ] des skinheads
et non mais c'est vrai mais il attaque
les marsouins il est utile et eu
carrément et puis il se frotte contre
les femelles il s'isole des femelles
pour les violer bon esprit le dauphin
vraiment compris les layènes se mêlent
se balade avec un pénis non c'est un
clic aux risques est tellement gros
qu'on croit que c'est un pénis à
briançon les pros tels à crois pas que
c'est un pénis ou croient qu'ils sont
des testicules avant je m'en rends pas
compte
passage deux marcassins dans le privé
les hippopotames fermer leur gueule et
moufte pas quand leurs femmes et là ça
dépend des hippopotames et les grandes
gueules parmi les hippopotames quand
même dans le privé de la mouche bat sa
femme
alors la mouche goûte la nourriture avec
ses pattes elle a des petits capteurs
sensoriels et elle goûte comme une
mouche se pose sur une merde en fin de
compte elle déguste
alors dans le privé les flamands roses
sont tous fait des rumeurs par une main
il ya beaucoup de moi dans le privé la
mante religieuse baisse comme une folle
avec son mari avant de lui arracher la
tête c'est la page où il est allé jouer
ou pas celle ci qu'elle est obligée
mantois
il ne peut évacuer que si on lui arrache
la tête a fait david et ben oui oui à
jouer dedans aussi
[Musique]
il
[Applaudissements]
la semaine maintenant
le dossier de la semaine et cette
semaine notre dossier c'est le
développement durable
vous savez alors vous savez que si on
n'arrête pas une minute la touche de
respirer on sauve autant de co2 qu'un
vol paris new york voulais pas tomber
c'est là ok attention je prête à tenter
les 50 ans un deux trois
donc le principe qui t'emmerde enfin
[Musique]
c'est vraiment parce que s'il croit pas
une seule seconde qu'il le fasse
à y respire par le cul
devrait jamais la planète
pour sauver la france ce qu'il faut
c'est de la croissance en revanche pour
sauver la planète c'est exactement
contraire si chaque terrien produisait
consomme et pollue autant qu'un français
moyen la terre deviendrai trois fois
trop site pour l'humanité mais on a beau
leur dire elle a répété ça hop et du
tiers-monde on dirait qu'il n'en a rien
à [ __ ] de l'écologie certains d'entre
eux ont des taux de croissance jusqu'à
cinq fois supérieur au nôtre alors s'il
continue à ne penser qu'à leur petite
gueule ils vont finir par nick et toute
la planète heureusement la france est là
pour leur montrer l'exemple avec la
semaine du développement durable par
solidarité avec la terre entière les
français vont désormais essayer de ne
pas oublier de bien fermer le robinet
quand il se lave les dents cela
suffira-t-il pour sauver le monde pas
sûr mais on s'en fout car les américains
ont découvert une méthode encore plus
radicale grâce à la crise financière
internationale
leur économie pourrait entrer en
récession et ça ce serait une
bénédiction
si les américains n'ont plus de fric ils
ne pourront plus acheter tout ce que la
revendre les chinois du coup les chinois
achètent moins de matières premières
pays africains résultat tout ce petit
monde produira moins consommera moins
polluera moins et la planète elle
respirera mieux alors bien sûr on n'a
pas fini d'entendre chouiner ceux qui
comptaient sur la croissance pour
améliorer leurs conditions de 8 mais
faut expliquer aux deux milliards
d'êtres humains qui vivent avec moins de
2 dollars par mois que s'ils cherchent à
gagner plus ça risque de tous me [ __ ]
dans la merde après tout lé pa ke la
planète nous on essaie de fermer le
robinet quand on se brosse les dents
alors eux aussi doivent faire un petit
effort
j'ai bien joué
voilà pour l'histoire aller simple tout
le monde philippe sur la croissance
nulle mais en fait la seule façon
d'assurer l'avenir de la planète cecchin
croissance nulle bike energy madame
écolos veulent maintenant t'es pas là
mais gros tu fais une émission qui
s'appelle planète 2048 car je suis
citoyenne et je m'intéresse à
l'environnement comme ça parce qu'ils
n'ont pas du tout moi je m'en branle
complètement c'est pas vrai c'est pas
vrai la preuve regarde si on va bien
réfléchir tu éduques un peu tes enfants
oui tu leur as appris est à la lumière
quand il sort d'une pièce jointe à la
longueur à cause des notes d'électricité
moi je vois là bas ça plaira d'en
avancer écolo aujourd'hui
présenté m'ont coupé christ et chez moi
je crois que tu es aveugle jusqu'à l'âge
de 14 ans
[Rires]
non même que la qualité soit dès 2015
comment est-ce qu'on peut sauver cette
[ __ ] de pleurer quand je veux dire je
n'ai pas de machine à laver tous les
gens viennent chez moi bien je lave la
vaisselle lave vaisselle tous les gens
qui me disaient
pollue monde d'avoir une machine à laver
celle ci avait sa main ce que veut dire
la plus grosse débauche
situe si tu l'as toute ta vaisselle dans
un bac et que tu rince à l'eau froide
j'utilise beaucoup moins de détergents
mais vas-y du monde l'attendait il ya
autre chose que sa cote reste à poser
les jeux les ogm ont souvent il faut
absolument interdire les ogm en france
il faut que comment il s'appelle qui
colle au gouvernement qu est sympa
borloo mais sans déconner il faut qu'ils
aient des couilles et qui disent non aux
ogm par exemple voilà il faut qu'on soit
derrière lui vous avez tous vu
l'émission sur arte à propos de monsanto
vous savez que c'est monsanto s'est
réglé les gens aux états unis qu'on
vendu le plus de saloperies dans le
monde et sont en train d essayer de
s'imposer en europe donc là il ya
vraiment un carrefour important un truc
qui va se jouer là il ne faut pas que
les ogm n'a pas ce problème c'est qu'en
france les gens se rendent pas compte
moi j'ai acheté une maison mexique il ya
15 ans j'avais la mer à peu près à 200
mètres de ma maison et en quinze ans la
mère est rentrée dans le jardin tout ça
à cause du réchauffement de la planète à
cause de la pollution à cause de
regarder les changements climatiques qui
sont absolument dramatiques quand j'ai
acheté cette maison il y avait un
ouragan une fois tous les sept ans qui
frappait les caraïbes on savait pas où
est maintenant les jamaïcains les
mexicains à tous on s'en prend 10 par an
qui commence au mois d'août et moi je l'
ai vu le réchauffement de la planète en
15 ans sur cette petite maison au
mexique sur la plage que j'ai vendu
parce que c'est fini la plage et romain
t il n'y a plus rien mexique mais la
chance qu'ils ont
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'accueille maintenant philippe tesson
l'an dernier et lundi
philippe tesson
je sens bon un ennemi d'henri droite
risbo il fête ses 80 ans ce soit
très très bon moment dans rive droite
rive gauche philippe et je tenais à ce
que tout soit là ce soir à bercy est
aussi les chiens
aboyer
[Applaudissements]
qui on avance et finalement la télé
l'athénée la terrine à tout ça on a
ramené le corps en effet graines de
stars après ils ont fait la nouvelle
star avec la star ac et xavier de
moulins donc il m'a succédé
dernière
c'est le bonus et dernier siège à
pourvoir la jalousie dans ce schéma 89
levier j'étais dans l'écurie de monsieur
en quatre ans j'aime beaucoup que
j'avais mais si tu le fais pas c'est
l'honnêteté des gens que tu payes pas tu
les as d'or toi cessa
jamais été transmis mal par mois pendant
trois ans la même ça n'a jamais trouvé
une émission pour la rentabiliser
à
tous ceux-là fortune d'ardisson l'air de
rien d'un quelle fortune
suppose qu'on n'a même pas un cheval et
non dans son art
alors pour mon anniversaire les auteurs
de cette émission
kader aoun stéphane ribeiro serna s'en
carre vous ont préparé un hardi quiz on
va voir si vous ne connaissez vraiment
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est quand j'y verse r si je
vois la
règle j'ai une collection de vieilles
voitures mais j'ai pas le permis
dès mon premier scandale dans une
interview descente de police dans quelle
folle premier quinquennat
[Applaudissements]
bien vrai ou faux j'ai été l'amant de
françoise sagan non forêt
non pas que les chutes annoncées la
prémisse iront tfue oui je connais
pas ta vie dénonce et puis à tous et
d'émotion
[Applaudissements]
à part faire du cinéma aux états unis il
parle lundi il rentre le mardi walf est
tout à fait vite ton film il fait bon
j'avais de l'herbe en arrivant
c'est la douane quelle première phrase
et je dit aux privilèges et une jeune
fille de 18 ans prénommé
attention voir si vous ne connaissez
bien quel est mon idole dans la vie
c'est gandhi
c'est le seul vivant qu'il aime
c'est bel et bien en quelle année et je
présente et lunettes noires pour nuits
blanches
2 qui est dit après notre première
rencontre ils pourraient être directeur
du marketing chez gervais danone a dû
carolis non non il aurait pu pourtant de
l'art gothique
ça vous fait chic et les pentes vraie
info entrevue qui s'appelait d'abord
interview devait en fait s'appelait
stupéfiants
comment s'appelle le roman dans lequel
j'ai pompé s'y passe
[Applaudissements]
nous
livre qu'est-ce que je ne porte jamais
d'elle
et de montres de montres il
faut vraiment trop j'ai déposé mon
propre nom aliens pays je me verse de
l'argent chaque fois que je signe un
papier
sur une duse habillés en noir pour une
émission vous me devait des royalties
l'épreuve portugaise de file du pognon
vert
vrai ou faux l'été je porte des maillots
de bain noir non non je n'ai pas
l'impression
maintenant exprime avec un petit fils
allait tout le monde
les charcuteries corses
[Musique]
je
ça
après pour la quatrième partie de sa
lucarne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous
ah ça
tim
wise as
chatel
[Musique]
sinon c'est drôle de six mois ça devient
lourdingue en fois ça devient long nous
ont rejoint
il aura l'occasion de l'anniversaire
donc c'est un champion de l'actu spécial
flash back pour faire plaisir à mon ami
laurent boyer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comment s'appelle we l'innocent condamné
en 2004 à 18 années de réclusion
criminelle pour le meurtre du pont de
neuilly à madame robert très remarquable
en pole chose marc machin joseph bidule
ou patrick truc
et
le 31 août 1997 lady di mourait sous le
pont de l'alma quels furent ses derniers
mots god save mais au my god oh my god
oh my god ailleurs
nom d'audi le chauffeur ne regarde
qu'est-ce qu'on s'éclate à paris
ma fille
quel couple mythique s'est formé en 1988
ségolène royal et françois hollande
cécilia ciganer albeniz et richard
attias à rien et miné d'un dernier
fontaine joeystarr et kool shen est
[Applaudissements]
selon qu'ils soient là le 17 mai 1990 à
supprimer l'organisation mondiale de la
santé de la liste des maladies mentales
les troubles de la personnalité
l'anorexie
l'homosexualité les toc ou la trisomie
21 à 20
[Applaudissements]
non
à l'été
voulait pas qu'on fasse les trente ans
maintenant
attention là ya pas de qcm une question
une réponse et commencent à appeler la
jeune fille qui tournait les cases la
roue de la fortune
laurenti chanté deux chansons
annie pujol
je
[Musique]
le 24 décembre 1994 un commando du gia
détour d'un avion qui s'était envolé
d'alger pour s'écraser sur l'elysée
contre l'arc de triomphe contre la tour
eiffel contre le moulin rouge ou
contrainte ou montbard
amar tou et contre murray fait
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mes gâteaux rivaux ont
signé georges
attention à tout
attention c'est un jour
très bien tous rêvent pas éviter ainsi
de ce que je gagne mais j'aimerais
qu'ils influent ont battu les coups de
la tête tout le monde aura fait long tu
tiens
ils ont dû de calme
qui a déclaré l'avoir comme père c'est
comme avoir une [ __ ] de 30 cm ça a des
avantages et des inconvénients
genre si
guillaume depardieu
anthony delon michaël goldman thomas
dutronc ou gaston
leroux
on a failli
bravo ils ont en
1997 jeanne calment mourait à l'âge à
ses 120 ans avec m
[Rires]
attention
1997 jeanne calment mouret à l'âge de
122 ans avant de mourir qui est elle
confie avoir dansé lorsqu'elle était
jeune il encore dit
victorino albert einstein pablo picasso
vincent van gogh ou michel 2
le 17 novembre 1993 qui a privé la
france de coupe du monde de foot
l'italie l'espagne la bulgare et la
suisse ou le portugal
le broker non
j'étais bien le mec qui a marqué le but
si les attendre que c'est à dire ouais
ouais
[Applaudissements]
depuis plus de trente ans il ya un an on
va rejouer
[Applaudissements]
il faut rester sur mon coup ça va aller
très vite
pour la faim depuis plus de trente ans
il ya un mensonge sur mon cv car en
réalité je n'ai jamais écrit quand c'est
trop c'est trop picot
je n'ai jamais eu de licence d'anglais
je n'ai jamais été dj oriska gogo agents
n'est pas je n'ai jamais couché avec la
première femme du shah d'iran je ne
m'habille pas en noir c'est du gris très
foncé
attention maintenant on passe au point
commun
quel est le point commun entre anne
roumanoff et frédéric beigbeder du bourg
vendredi au paraguay la même promo à
sciences po bravo saviez
pour les personnes de la dire
quel est le point commun champollion
concernés
quel point commun entre béziers et l'on
ma fille hilux à dallas le tass bravo
c'est pas classe c'est la classe quel
est le point commun entre bruno solo et
marlon brando
le tee shirt c'est vrai aussi mais c'est
grave ça finit au nom
moi je sais il le sait mais dira rien
ils ont tous les deux jouer le même
personnage historique gelabale et
napoléon bras il avait dit
il ému
médina les dernières
avaient dit napoléon dans une autre
édition j'aime vraiment ce club il ya
quel est le point commun entre christine
bravo et yvan le bolloc'h qu'on a tous
les deux instituteurs voire avant
[Applaudissements]
point commun entre thierry ardisson et
william leymergie
l'étranglement non
au talon
c'est dur pour wii appel à tous les deux
virées france 2 non sans voir toi mais
je me suis jetée fait les deux
ikin pas comme entre laurent ruquier et
bolloc'h et solo maintenant
on l'a fait de la radio que le tard en
juin
mousse etc là on n'est pas couché ouais
vous ils tirent en veut
tout va se décider au blind test
[Applaudissements]
j'avais l'interprète on y va
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pamiers faire
connaître
l
agence implantée
[Applaudissements]
la vie politique
john solecki servait côté
[Musique]
la mémoire
marçais
trois classes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
grammophon
malien mustapha el nous devons faire
tout ça
dec
la ville a mis le feu
mais non mais non le clip avec le chien
chien des plus beaux qu'il a même dit
c'est le live
des joueurs pour cela
m
[Musique]
lee ah je laime survie williams
attention
[Musique]
non ce soir non allez nature il ya un
truc qui se passe ce soir y'a un truc
qui se passe ce soir c'est que mustapha
est en train de torches et belle fille
aux bundles et sa s'élève à c'est
historique ça ce qui se passe se soit
excusé moi est faux que le ramène
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
or
[Applaudissements]
ouais et plus
par hasard
c'est faux
[Applaudissements]
non sophie gestion
sophie avec son énorme énorme et lord up
[Musique]
tout ça c'est de la connerie celui ou
celle qui va trouver cette chanson aura
tout gagné de tout le concours
attention la punition tech et les gens
ici qui veulent maintenant
je veux l'interprète vous êtes prêts
tout est remis à zéro
[Musique]
je demande ma fille je le sais c'est
quoi bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et alors
sera pas une parce que c'est mon
anniversaire
la punition c'est qu'on va tous
s'embrasser musique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la soirée a dit garcia continue sur
canal jimmy une chaîne du groupe canal
avec un documentaire qui sont vingt ans
d'antenne voilà je vous laisse avec la
séance samedi soir box office et ce soir
c'est taxi 4 on se retrouvait semaine
prochaine salut les terriens
[Musique]
des corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux